the futuristic film minority report Tom
Cruise uses special gloves as seen in
this clip and a trio of psychics to
track down criminals before they commit
a crime ramy params ambitions are more
modest he wants to unchain us from our
devices and turn the world around us
into a more interactive won his first
target overhead projectors with one
minute installation process you can take
any one of the 50 million projectors
installed worldwide plus ten ten million
shipments every year and gents transform
them from a regular projector into an
interactive room just like that by
putting the bird on your finger the bird
which fits on your index finger is just
half of MU v's technology agent yes
please Google Earth to the table can
also project the image on any device
onto any surface and allowing you to
interact with it as if you were there
agent yes please iphone to the sofa
the agent is still at the development
stage I'd prefer we don't show the
working prototype but its impact could
be just as impressive as corning's
vision of the future except the maker of
gorilla glass screens for iPads is
betting on almost everything being
coated in touch sensitive glass we think
the Porsche is toward natural user
interfaces voice gesture movement and
touch are all parts of that when you
think of touch specifically maybe you've
seen a toddler interact with a tablet or
a smartphone it's very natural for them
and that intuitive nature is why we
think touch stays around for a long time
covering everything in glass may not be
everyone's cup of tea it's quite
expensive for a start whichever vision
comes out on top science fiction
technology looks to be heading to a
screen or a surface near you very soon
and it got can Bloomberg hurts Leah
Israel